considerada la opción nuclear de las
sanciones tras la invasión rusa de
ucrania aumentan los llamados a excluir
a rusia del sistema swift se trata de la
red mundial de transferencias económicas
swift es la estructura esencial del
sistema bancario internacional basado en
bélgica el servicio conecta cerca de 11
mil entidades financieras alrededor del
mundo facilitando más de 40 millones de
transacciones al día expulsar a moscú
del swift podría devastar la economía
rusa los movimientos económicos
transfronterizos serían mucho más
complicados y caros para las
instituciones financieras del país lo
que perjudicaría gravemente el comercio
exterior ruso decidió videla súbito el
swift es el último recurso por eso una
de las opciones que está sobre la mesa
sometido
dado que rusia es el quinto mayor socio
comercial de la unión europea excluirla
del swift perjudicaría también la
economía del bloque comunitario tanto al
recibir pagos de crédito ruso como al
pagar a rusia por su suministro de gas
imprescindible para europa sin embargo
rusia ya está buscando alternativas
adelantándose a la posible expulsión
brazzers
sólo para lado rusia está desarrollando
su propio sistema swift paralelo
evidentemente si se excluye a rusia del
swift rusia simplemente intentará
desarrollar su propio sistema junto con
china y lo convertirían en un competidor
del swift implicaba a camps ver el
sistema de pago interbancario
transfronterizo de china también podría
ser una alternativa aunque por ahora es
mucho más pequeño que el swift así que
moscú podría encontrarse en una posición
parecida a la de irán el país fue
expulsado del swift en 2012 y en
consecuencia perdió la mitad de sus
ingresos por la exportación de petróleo
y el 30 por ciento de su comercio
exterior